TO THE ALL-STAR BREAK.
THERE IS PATRIK LAINE, WHO
IDOLIZED THE GREAT 8 GROWING UP
IN HIS NATIVE FINLAN, BOTH
TEAMS, WELL RESTED.
COLUMBUS, ESPECIALLYFLICKS WANT.
THAT WAS BROKEN UP AT FRONT.
IT'S BEEN A LIDEFENSEMANM, TWO-H
CARLSON.
CARLSON, CLOSING.
FANS ON A SNAPSHOT.
CARLSON GET THE CHANCE TO
TO SET UP ON THE POWER PLAY.
>> Joe: WERENSKI TAKES THEEEN PT
HOCKEY RECENTLY.
HE'S BEEN REWARDED FOR HANGING
OUT IN THE PAINT, AND  THE GREA.
NYQUIST, HE WRAPPED UPON THE NE.
>> Craig: RIODS.
THE END PERIODS.
OUT, WITH A LITTLE PATH,
CHIPSET ACROSS AND GOES OFF THEH
FEHERVARY.
HERE'S THE CENTER MAN.
THERE IS THE SHO ON 1 SHORTHAND
THOS  TIC-TAC-TOE, AND
ANOTHER TOE TO BOQVIST.
ONE PASS, TO PASSES ACROSS,
THEN THE THIRD PASS ARY ASSIST.
BEAUTIFUL RINK WIDE PASS.
GAVRIKOV WAS IN THE LANE HOUSE.
HE HAS A LITTLE MORE EXCHANGE
OF BODYWEIGHT FROM BACK FOOT TO
FRONT FOOT, MORE SO THAN
REAL GOOD SHOT HERE.
HERE IT IS ON THE DROP HERE
JENNER, LU Joe: LARSEN HAD A GO
AGAINST  THE OILERS AND
WASHINGTON/EVERETT BEFORE TH
NOD
WITH IS LATE, IT IS 3-4 FOR THE
OUT OF HARM'S WAY.
>> Joe: WE WILL WAY TO SEE HOW
LONG
OLD HOCKEY SAVE E  HIS WAY TO T
WASHINGTON BENCHOF TIME, AND THK
UP ON THEIR FEET HERE IN
CAPITAL ONE.
IT'S BEEN AN ONSLAUGHT BY THE
CAPS, TRYINGERTIME RECORD IN THE
REBOUND, AND WHAT A PLAY BY
NYQUIST.
GIVE HIM CREDIT WHERE CREDIT